[Musique]
j'adore le thé c'est vrai le choisir le
préparer le servir et le déguster avec
quelqu'un d'autre au japon donc la
cérémonie du thé appelé chat nouilles ou
dure entre 1h et 4h est sous-tendue par
quatre valeurs essentielles qui sont la
pureté la tranquillité le respect et
l'harmonie j'adore mon entreprise aller
au contact des heures et des autres
l'entreprise pour moi est un organisme
vivant au même titre que nous autres
êtres humains tout bouge constamment et
vins ce rapport au vivant
la pureté la tranquillité le respect
l'harmonie sont des valeurs essentielles
à son bon développement
être patron ou l'art de l'infusion l'art
du thé à l'occidentale d'abord choisir
pour le thé son contenant c'est
important
dans quel réceptacle déjà cueillir les
précieuses feuilles pour qu'ils
expriment tout leur parfum dans quelle
structure déjà accueillir les hommes et
les femmes dans l'entreprise quelle
bureaux quai locaux quels sites de
production petits grands modernes
rustique à ce projet j'envoie mon sens
un premier message
qu'est-ce qui est derrière en tant que
patron le bien-être la productivité
peut-être une combinaison des deux je me
rappelle il ya quelques années nous
étions dans des bureaux paysagers à côté
du stade de l'est glacial et les bureaux
devenait un peu petit pour nous la nôtre
puisque rossi s'est fortement et ça
devenait un peu difficile à tel point
par exemple quand je parlais au
téléphone je vais tendance à parler fort
j'étais commercial cette époque là dans
l'entreprise et exportant pas mal et je
parlais souvent à l'étranger
et puis cet été l'om plus je criais fort
comme s'il fallait que je l'autre matin
dans l'autre bout d'australie ça pouvait
donner un halo ou iard au darfour et du
colis from australia and find you
j'avais les regards des autres les
bureaux c'est comme ça dans le jour on a
décidé de changer de locaux devenus trop
petits on a réfléchi tous ensemble avec
l'équipe à
dans quel espace nous souhaitions
travailler évolué de bureaux paysagers
me sont passés du bureau fermé pour
certains et pour d'autres les bureaux
plus distants les uns des autres
nous avions mis plus de distance entre
nous
de vide et je me souviens de la première
fois où j'ai intégré les nouveaux
bureaux et de ma sensation de
d'étonnement et de ravissement au
travail en me disant mais les conflits
s'était apaisé la communication s'était
largement améliorée avec un invité de
taille le silence et je pouvais
désormais choisir d'aller à la rencontre
des autres et ne plus subir cette
rencontre nous avions mis lettre au
centre les besoins de lettres centre on
était passé de la théière électrique en
plastique à la théière traditionnelle en
fonte
après le choix du contenant de la
structure bien celui des accessoires
alors les accessoires wii alors que
choisir le petit sachet de thé vous
saviez suivi qu'à cette ficelle est là
qui finit toujours par se casser la
gueule d'ange dans le truc là dans la
tasse il faut le prendre on se brûle la
passeure en plastique pas très élégante
ça dégouline un petit peu la boule à thé
aussi ça nous fait comme vice comme
dévissant nous faut partout en général
et puis je trouve que le thé vraiment
très compact l intérieur et il respire
pas été là moi je préfère le filtre en
métal celui qu'on pose sur la bouche de
la théière en fonte
il s est respiré les feuillants elles
peuvent se livrer tranquillement petite
cuillère en bambou je vais choisir pour
attraper le thé en poudre vert ou bien
les serviettes qui vont servir à
nettoyer et séchez les ustensiles et les
bols ou bien c'est le choix d'un vase
sobre pour accueillir un bouquet tout en
harmonie couleurs ramené à mon
entreprise quels outils et quelle
machine 1 je vais utiliser
je vais choisir en général j'aime bien
les choses qui sont belle et utile
pratique il ya toujours un coin de moi
qui pense au bien-être dans le faire ne
pas galérer parce qu'internet va de à
l'heure où bien qu'il faut un store pour
protéger du soleil manga sous le poids
de travail qui l'a pas aucune machine
ton sans arrêt en panne ayant parlé en
panne dans l'entreprise que je codirige
avec mon frère nous avons choisi
d'alléger la pénibilité des ouvriers
nous produisons des bars et que pour le
vin travail artisanal mais aussi
industriel alléger la pénibilité était
un des facteurs clés pour nous alors on
investit dans des belles machines par
exemple pour soulever des gros morceaux
de bois mais aussi pour remplacer des
opérations très très répétitives on a
aussi choisi
d'équipé ateliers de bardage micro
perforé pour insonoriser pour que le
sens à absorber et essayer de tamiser de
diminuer un petit peu les six qui
virevoltent qu'il faut un vacarme diable
mais c'est aussi un logiciel acheté pour
qu'ils aient plus beaucoup plus
ergonomique et qui va permettre une
fluidité la production ou encore se
faire rentrer du beau jeu vous rappelez
des outils beau utile mais faire un
trait du beau dans les bureaux des beaux
matériaux une oeuvre d'art une peinture
dans l'atelier une deuxième des photos
le bout qui rentre dans l'entreprise
et cet accessoire la ses accessoires la
ses machines ses outils c'est essentiel
et je crois que pour bien-être humain il
faut se sentir bien avec son
environnement technique mécanique
immatériel a maintenant j'aimerais vous
faire revenir sur la cérémonie du thé
mais qu'est ce qui donne le parfum
l'originalité la saveur des feuilles de
thé
de thé pour moi c'est comme les 120
collaborateurs dont l'entreprise
chacune est unique et respectable et
c'est le subtil assemblage de chacune
des feuilles qui va faire que le
breuvage sera merveilleux ou pas il se
pose la question mais avec qui j'avais
travaillé
quel parfum choisir pour monter un thé
fort et puissant du japon était délicat
de ceylan je sais pas vous mais dans la
vie moi je recherche l'amour et dans
l'entreprise aussi c'est pas me priver
amour entreprises il prévient amour
l'amour et notamment l'amour de la
relation alors quand je recrute
eh bien j'ai à l'esprit que l'état
d'esprit justement l'état d'être de la
personne que j'ai en face est importante
je me dis on je trouverai toujours
montée initiale mais quelqu'un qui saura
vivre et travailler avec l'autre me
semble beaucoup plus important
l'amour dans l'entreprise la relation
les feuilles de thé les personnalités
goûter
c'est un peu comme si j'allais au
supermarché j'étais pas cher c'est un
serveur peut-être il serait au bout de
sa ficelle pendouillant comme ça là je
le plongerait je me ferais refusé le
goût très je miserais beau mais c'est
pas bon je fasse plaisir et cette
recherche de plaisir à être ensemble
nous réjouit particulièrement alors pour
permettre pour qu'est-ce qui fait le
lien j'ai vraiment que ce parfum qui est
là qui est potentiellement existe en
chacun de nous chacun des ouvriers
employés des gens qui je travaille mais
qu'est ce qui va permettre qu est ce qu
est le lien qui met en contact pendant
qu'ils libèrent qui révèle c'est quoi
ces lots oui l'eau et sa première
fonction c'est de nettoyer
elle doit être pur au japon le maître de
cérémonie
vu la première chose qui fait c'est de
purifier ses ustensiles et c'est bol ils
sont pros après je vous rassure il n'y a
pas juste non ils sont propres mais il a
les purifier alors moi j'ai envie de me
purifier aussi j'ai envie que ce qui
coule en moi ce qui coule deux mois soit
le plus pur possible mon eau de vie
alors on peut se dire je me suis dit
mais me nettoyer de quoi jeu propre jeu
sont bonnes tout c'est pas le problème
même nettoyé de mes peurs mais nettoyer
de mon ego qui vous assurent parfois est
un peu surdimensionné de nettoyer au cid
envie de dominer l'autre l'envi de
d'exister ou de saintes siens que
j'existe parce que je suis quelqu'un
dans l'entreprise
je suis patron et on me regarde mais
aussi la vie de nettoyer de
l'identification à l'entreprise
vous savez c'est le fameux
on croise un pote dans la rue et pose la
question
ça va ta boîte bon je viens moi je
réponds moi je vais bien j'ai un chiffre
d'affaires en croissance
j'ai fait des supers vente j'ai fait
l'espagne un super bénéfices c'est super
par contre j'ai pris mme prud'homme et
et puis j'ai perdu 30 pinheiro qu'un
client italien qui va payer je je je
un jour je me suis même c'est pas juste
à temps si je réfléchis bière
l'organisme et vivant qu'est
l'entreprise
mais c'est elle qui gagnent de l'argent
c'est elle qui a une croissance
c'est elle qui a pris auprès d'hommes et
qui a perdu 30 millions en italie avec
le client de la zone d'agricola bambini
c'est pas moi et je vous garantis que le
jour où j'ai pris conscience de ça je
vous refais comme le schéma entreprise
familiale à narbonne
cent trente cinq ans d'existence
quand je suis né l'entreprise a fait
faillite
mon père a tout repris à tour montés
nous a transmis ce avec mon frère est
costaud ça c'était costaud et puis donc
je me suis dit mais finalement mais si
l'entreprise elmer j'ai fait faillite ou
bien si je la vends mais moi je me
repart
ce nettoyage il est très personnel il ya
comme qui peut le faire c'est moi en
tant qu'être humain pas tant que patron
en tant qu'être humain chaque instant il
est lent il est progressif et tête vous
savez aussi ça vous le fait ça mais des
fois j'ai des rechutes merde
de sorte que le tb il n'est pas toujours
très bon no fil du temps je vous
garantis qui s'améliore tiens magnifique
drapeau du japon
magnifique ichigo ichi est une fois une
rencontre une fois une rencontre
c'est ce que disait japonais quand ils
vivent cette rencontre autour du thé ils
voient ça comme un trésor quelque chose
d'unique qui ne se reproduira jamais
exactement pareil jamais ichigo ichi
trouve ça magnifique et la 7e rencontre
la place à l'instant présent elle est
fondamental la capacité que j'ai à me
connecter à moi à l'autre à mes émotions
aux émotions de l'autre voire être vus
reconnu
reconnecter que nous faisons nous des
réunions de nos réunions de direction
générale à trois avec pierre et julien
mais fréquemment nous commençons la
réunion on décore un peu bilan même pas
un bilan on se dit les choses
comment je suis comme les résistances
des peurs ce qui est là qui est je ne me
c'est pareil je veux divorcer
je suis touché je me sens fragilité un
résistance j'ai aucune envie d'être là
ce qui hélas important est fréquemment
nos larmes coulent à la réunion est
fréquemment au bout de ce que je vois ça
dure pas cinq minutes et d'une heure ou
deux général à se dire les choses comme
ça edit bon mais la time out et on part
du bureau et en faire un tour à la mer
on va faire un tour sur le bord du canal
boire une bière est fréquemment à des
moments qui nous cueille bien large
sourire s'invite sur nos visages et nos
coeurs s'ouvre est fréquemment quand
nous revenons à parler de travail du
boulou en général on a délocalisé la
réunion c'est plus lourd on est parti
dans un bar et on parle des décisions à
prendre qui sont parfois importantes
mais je vous garantis que j'ai vraiment
la sensation que nos choix sont beaucoup
plus cohérent nourrissant et bon pour
l'entreprise nettoyé par notre tente ici
tu es sincérité et en pâtit les uns par
les autres
ouais mais alors alors les chiffres les
résultats chiffre d'affaires tout ça
mais n'en parle pas ça intéresse pas
mais j'adore j'adore j'adore mais
quelles entreprises gagnent de l'argent
je dois qu'elle soit rentable
j'adore être que soient bien gérés il
faut continuer à payer ses salariés
continuent à investir donner du mou
qu'il ya besoin d'être toujours tendue
sur le fil du rasoir donc avoir une
bonne trésorerie c'est important et pas
qu'on ne va pas être l'objectif non
l'objectif pour moi il est entreprise
d'avoir du sens le projet que porte
l'entreprise
cet organisme est vivant kibaki vie qui
bouge d'avoir du sens des valeurs
c'est important que chacun de trouver sa
place la prennent même et trouve du sens
un ski fis qui soit heureux dans ce
qu'il fait et moi ma contribution à ça
ça a été de lâcher le contrôle et
justement les résultats ça n'a pas été
toujours très simple rappelé l'ego
surdimensionné mais par exemple je signe
pas l'échec dans l'entreprise les
commandes du contrôle pas les finances
sont elles qui te vole de l'argent ou
c'est encore le séminaire qu'on fait
tous les deux ans dans l'entreprise
trentaine de collaborateurs et cette
année on a décidé de leur confier un
budget un espace temps une semaine ils
choisissent
la destination ce fut l'étranger pour
vous cette année les soirées les
activités l'esprit et moi je participe
j'ai donné l'impulsion je me dégage du
centre et je participe et seule flotte à
cet instant-là mono de j qui est pour
moi l'esprit qui m'anime mes valeurs mes
intentions mais aussi pas avoir de
conséquences l'esprit de l'entreprise
qui à chaque instant avec bienveillance
infuse
chacun des membres est le maître de
cérémonie lui-même
là je m'imagine au japon j'ai un petit
tout dans les cheveux l'a oublié je
porte en kimono mais j'ai les pieds nus
en toute simplicité
je prépare la cérémonie du thé la fête
de l'entreprise en conscience dans la
pureté la tranquillité le respect et
l'harmonie mon frère est à mes côtés et
il va faire pleurer je le regarde il me
regarde on y compris ça et je me sens
bien
les invités vont arriver oui les invités
vont arriver ils vont déguster ce thé
parfumé merveilleux authentique original
un seul mot un maître mot
être ensemble
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]